in the Somali capital Mogadishu a group
of journalists has gathered to protest
against what they say is an attack on
freedom of speech by their government
unlike today we are standing here to
protest about the arrest of our
colleagues as Somali journalists we
demand justice for all reporters behind
bars the Constitution is quite clear
that no one can be detained for more
than 48 hours without being put on trial
according to Human Rights Award Somali
authorities have detained three
journalists and prohibited a local radio
station from broadcasting in a local
dialect in the past two months one of
the detained journalists is Muhammad
Abdul Wahab new editor of hexie radio he
was arrested on March 7th after
reporting on police brutality in the
capital his family says they've been
denied access to their son so it's very
worrying that they've labelled my son a
terrorist for only practicing his
profession I appeal to our national
leaders for the release of my son he was
our only breadwinner and we haven't seen
him for a whole two months I wanted
justice for my son journalists unions in
the country often protest about the
outdated Penal Code which came into
force in 1964 it includes a number of
vague and overly broad crimes including
criminal deformation offending the owner
and prestige of the head of state in
assaulting a public officer or
institution all judges frequently lead
against journalists what we are seeing
these days or these weeks or mounties is
an organized campaign to criminalize
journalism by booting journalists in
court because of their media riotous or
because of the right to freedom of
expression and especially the use of
criminal laws which are already outdated
and draconian such as the banal code of
Somalia which was enacted in 1964
according to the Committee to Protect
Journalists Somalia is one of the most
dangerous countries in the world for
journalists they often face threats and
attacks from government officials
private individuals and the armed group
al-shabaab the right group says impunity
for the killing of journalists remain
the norm with at least 69 journalists
killed since 1991 when Somali Civil War
began
pomerode o al Jazeera let's take this on
weekly speaker Leticia Bader who is a
senior researcher at Human Rights Watch
the Africa division and he joins us on
skype from Rome and Leticia tell us
first how serious the problem has become
in Somalia since the pandemic began
Leticia
bata can you hear me